i gotta ask you
uh are your night terrors getting any
better
i i heard i said we can cut that out if
you want but i was just i was so curious
about that
well so we
wait what are night terrors i guess
we're gonna because scott scott
you know it was was poking around the
internet and uh
doing some research on you he learns
that you have what's called night
terrors and what what does that even
mean
um it's a good question kind of like you
ever seen a sixth sense like the
i see dead people kid yeah so
everyone has a lot of there's all
different types or whatever but i feel
like i'm fully awake um
and obviously i'm not awake but i feel
like i am
i'm in pla wherever i went to sleep and
you wake up and um
a lot of weird stuff um yeah for
instance i knocked out my tooth uh
there was basically a big dog
chasing me and i woke up and i'm running
i dove down the
steps and as i'm in the air diving down
the steps i'm like
there's no dog in my room and i busted
out my front tooth
uh so that's the only tooth i lost was
actually uh from from a night terror
uh you know basically i
see stuff in the in the fire uh when the
fire is not on
um it's it's a little strange um so
interestingly enough
when you're traveling a lot you run down
a lot you're run down on b vitamins
uh b vitamins is what's your energy but
that also creates melatonin
so melatonin is what helps keep you
asleep so a lot of times if you really
run down
you'll see a lot of the military guys
have it a lot of uh action sports people
have it
uh sheckler actually has night terrors
which was really funny because
i took off yelling screaming running one
way this is a long time ago sheckler was
yelling screaming running the other way
and my roommate you normally uh
chris haynes who normally didn't care if
he heard me running he's like i
he was like out the door and underwear
like what's going on we're like oh just
night terrors he's like well if just one
of you i wouldn't have been so concerned
two of you all running from opposite
rooms in different directions so does
that does that mean that
that it happens while you're asleep is
it like a
dreaming and you're having a nightmare
kind of thing or uh
yeah for the most part so like for
instance uh my
one of the first times i had a night
terror i was like 12 years old and
um you know i was in a hotel room with
my parents out in vegas and they woke up
and the doors open
i my feet were all bloody i had run
about a half mile across the desert from
from our motel 6 just in my underwear
barefoot
full sprint before i noticed that uh you
know that i was
dreaming or what i was running from so
so i
go back to a couple years ago um
i was on an airplane and it was i fell
asleep while i was on the runway and
this is what i'm most afraid of is like
this
you know one of those those uh agents
are gonna be on and i'm gonna be running
towards the cockpit luckily i was
running towards the back of the plane
and not towards the front of the plane
screaming at the top of my lines
running as fast as i can in the back of
the plane we're still on the runway
and they're like everyone please sit
down so we can take off and i had to
walk
back past every one of these people i'm
sorry my dad
was like what the hell just happened
so i try not to fall asleep on planes
anymore although the night chairs are
getting better
uh but i had an awesome hotel room in
vegas and um
i was about to go to sleep with all the
doors open and i was like man this is a
bad idea
wake up jumping off the side of the
building so i try to double latch all
the doors and try to make sure that i
wake up before i do anything stupid is
there any footage of you having night
terrors
no no and if there was i would
definitely not tell you
[Laughter]
yeah dude